sometimes we go to movies too laughs
sometimes we go to cry and sometimes we
want to have our minds melted no medium
like film can take you on a psychedelic
trip make you question the nature of
everything around you or get you inside
the headspace of the truly deranged and
that appears that next year will bring a
ton of movies designs to blow everyone's
minds here are the 2018 movies that are
bound to be weird in the very best ways
annihilation based on Jeff van der Meers
2014 novel annihilation looks to be a
crazy cinematic experience the film
follows an expedition to a place called
area X a portion of the earth where
everything has gone wrong and the laws
of physics no longer seem to apply
previous missions to area X have gone
south 11 times over written and directed
by ex machina Salix garland annihilation
will star Jennifer Jason Leigh and
Natalie Portman in this atmospherically
creepy film that hits theaters February
23rd a wrinkle in time Madeleine L'Engle
1962 young adult novel a wrinkle in time
has been blasting young brains for
generations it's the story of precocious
kids who must rescue their dad from a
fate worse than death
with the help of interdimensional beings
mrs. whatsit mrs. Who and mrs. which the
books more surreal aspects have made it
difficult to adapt to a live-action
production but with selma director Ava
Duvernay and an all-star cast fans can
expect an updated yet faithful rendition
of this otherworldly classic when it
debuts on a silver screen March 9th
ready player one Ernest Cline's novel
ready player one had secured a film deal
before the book was even in stores with
Steven Spielberg anxious to develop the
story for film the story centers on a
virtual reality gamer in a dystopian
future who must run a gauntlet of 80s
pop culture themed challenges while
looking for an easter egg in the trailer
alone there were millions of references
from The Iron Giant - back to the future
- Freddy Krueger prepare for nerd
culture overload when this pic hits
theaters on March 30th abruptio from
writer director evan mallow comes
abruptio a thriller centered on a man
who has a bomb implanted in his neck and
must do terrible things to keep it from
exploding as actor James Marsters
explained the lead character is feeding
bodies in
right and that's not even a bad but he's
so bad if that's not strange enough
it'll also be performed by life-sized
latex puppets we'll just have to wait to
see whether it's a work of genius
madness or both when abruptio gets
released on May 31st Aleta
battle angel the live-action adaptation
of the post-apocalyptic manga and anime
battle angel Aleta has been in the works
since 2010 when the project was brought
to James Cameron's attention by
Guillermo del Toro Cameron had
originally intended to direct but with
his plate all full of avatars he calls
for the next several years but duty has
fallen to Robert Rodriguez the cast is
already stacked with talent like Rosa
Salazar Jackie Earle Haley maja Sheila
Ali Christophe volts and the Jennifer
Connelly and one of Cameron's signature
filmmaking strategies will live on with
the film since Cameron only makes films
that start with T or a it's now called a
Lita battle angel and will land in
theaters on July 20th captive States
this sci-fi thriller has a cerebral
concept
what would your average neighborhood
look like a decade or so after an
occupation by a hostile force that just
so happened to be extraterrestrial
captive states will diverge from
ordinary alien fare to explore the human
dynamics between the dissidents and
collaborator with Rupert Wyatt of the
modern planets of the apes pics of the
helm you can count on this one to be a
disturbing hit when August 17th rolls
around mortal engines philip reeves the
mortal engines books introduce a
post-apocalyptic concept of traveling
cities scouring a devastated earth and
doing battle with each other such a
large-scale project seems untenable but
with Peter Jackson Co scripting along
with his Lord of the Rings co-writers
Fran Walsh and Philippa boyens the
project already seems to be in good
hands
Kristian rivers who served a second unit
director on all three Lord of the Rings
films will make his feature film debut
with the pick which drops on December
14th
the endless filmmakers Aaron Moorhead
and Justin Benson have teamed up again
after their 2012 thriller resolution to
star as a pair of brothers who have
escaped the clutches of a cult but a
compelled to return years later by a
mysterious tape Center the male early
images from the film hinted a trippy
visual aesthetic and the plot synopsis
suggests a cult crazy otherworldly
beliefs maybe aren't so crazy after all
it all adds up to a project that just
might be worth keeping a close eye on
coming from a pair of ambitious
filmmakers who seemed jus for a breakout
hit the house that Jack built
not many filmmakers are as visually
provocative as lars von trier but his
forthcoming the house that Jack built
has a truly and settling premise it's an
examination of the career of a serial
killer who has been active for more than
a decade and who views each of his
murders as a work of art in the hands of
von trier such a story promises a deep
dark psychological ride sorry to bother
you a story set in a surreal version of
Oakland California sorry to bother you
is the story of a down-on-his-luck black
telemarketer who discovers a magical key
to upward mobility the ability to make
his voice sound like a famous white
actor the film will mark the directorial
debut of legendary rapper boots Riley of
Oakland rap group the coup which has
spent over two decades making some of
the most subversive music anyone has
ever heard keep an eye out for this one
next year the man who killed Don Quixote
perhaps though feature film has enjoyed
such a rocky right two screens as
director Terry Gilliam's the man who
killed Don Quixote his quest to get the
film made long ago began to mirror the
foolish futile endeavors of the classic
literary character but Gilliam's labor
of love is finally coming to theaters
next year the story focuses on an old
man who believes he is the legendary
Quixote and mistakes are confused
advertising executive for his faithful
Squire he then proceeds to drag the man
through a time jumping mind-bending
adventure where dreams and reality
become tough to tell apart in version
the sci-fi thriller inversion has two
things going for it right off the bat
samuel l.jackson and that insane premise
Jackson will portray a homeland security
investigator hot on the trail of an
American conman and the Chinese
scientist who he thinks are responsible
for a whole new type of natural disaster
sudden unexplained loss of gravity the
pic is sure to be a spectacle when it
falls into theaters next year the
Mandela effect groupthink can be a
strange thing and the Mandela effect is
a term meant to describe the effect of
people collectively remembering false
events like the death of Nelson Mandela
in prison
1980s or Sinbad starring in a movie of
alta genie and for the record no really
neither of those things happened in our
reality at least since memory is highly
unreliable it's an effect to which
almost anyone is susceptible so
co-writer and director David guy levy
will tap their trend for the Mandela
effect the film will feature a man for
whom the everyday details of the world
begin to change and keep changing until
he starts to question the nature of
reality itself Night on Bald Mountain
of all the Disney reboots in production
the live-action adaptation of Night on
Bald Mountain the scariest Trippier
segments from Fantasia has somehow flown
under the radar the segment features a
towering demonic winged creature called
Chernabog that presides over a nights of
festivities for a host of restless
spirits the new version will focus on
the backstory of the demonic creature
you can depend on this pic to rekindle
your childhood nightmares next year
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your lofty
[Music]